Before you go into the room with
your user, you'll want to figure out
exactly how you want to record
data from your interaction.
Generally speaking,
you have three options.
You can take notes directly,
which is the easiest to get users to
agree to, and does a really good job of
allowing you to pull out the things that
sound important to you in the moment.
Writing notes also means that you
don't need to take time later on to
sift through the feedback again.
You can also ask for permission to
record the audio of the conversation.
In the next video, we'll introduce
you to the concept of talk aloud,
which will be key to user research,
and also allow you to get great feedback
through the voice of your user.
This is great because it allows you to
focus on the testing as its going on and
sift through the data later.
Additionally, you will often catch
really useful snippets of things you
did right.
Nothing convinces investors quite so
much as hearing a user be verbally
excited about your app design
as they're interacting with it.
Nothing, that is, except for
seeing that user be excited
about interacting with the app.
If you have the resources and
are able to get permission,
it can be really useful to record video
of both the prototype as the user's
interacting with it, and the user's face
as their interacting with the prototype.
This footage takes awhile
to sift through, and so,
is mainly appropriate for
higher fidelity prototypes later on.
But can be really useful in
presentations to investors.
I would suggest that for the sake of the
first prototype, you just take notes.
It's always vital to have a record but
for
the moment we're wanting to get
feedback as fast as possible.